as health secretary matt hancock had the
most important job in government
when the country's greatest peacetime
crisis struck his competence tested like
few before him
his credibility ultimately strained to
breaking point
by his own actions appointed by theresa
may in 2018
his priorities were nhs staff morale and
the care sector
though he never got beyond minting a
badge when theresa may resigned he stood
to succeed her
kept on by boris johnson coronavirus
defined his time in office
and his fall hancock was central to
setting the terms of lockdowns
that put unprecedented restrictions on
personal freedoms
and police the most intimate elements of
people's lives
this is on all of us of course it's on
us at the podium
to do our duty and play our part but
it's on
you as well every single person needs to
keep sticking to those rules
stay at home protect the nhs and save
lives
those restrictions did not prevent the
virus running rampant in care homes
and he was criticized as the nhs ran
short of ppe
and the multi-billion pound test and
race system struggled to keep
pace with the pandemic he was quick to
condemn those who breached the rules
including key government adviser
professor neil ferguson
who admitted to an extramarital affair
at the peak of the first wave
it's extraordinary and um you know
i i i i don't understand the speechless
i i
am i that doesn't often happen to me i
think that he took the right decision
you wouldn't have to resign yeah you
wouldn't afford to keep him
it's just not that's just not possible
in these circumstances in the second
wave when
mixing remained illegal indoors hancock
told people not to hug their grandma
and said the rules barred new intimate
relationships
it just means that people need to be
careful right people need to be sensible
and if you're in a relationship that is
uh
that is well established you know that's
that's what like
six months what it means is not people
realizing that by
by coming into close contact with people
in
other households then that is
how the virus spreads i wouldn't suggest
bending the rules i would suggest
sticking to them letter and spin
despite the success of a vaccine program
that has hit all its targets
the political weather had turned against
hancock recently
former prime ministerial advisor dominic
cummings released messages in which
boris johnson called his health
secretary
hopeless are you hopeless mr hancock i
don't think so
he was not without support in the
highest places
the queen expressing sympathy i've just
been talking to your
sexual safe health foreman and he came
for
proofing cancer oh yes he's full of
bees yes things are getting better
a newspaper front page a few days later
told a different story
matt hancock's personal transgressions
in public office
proving an offence even boris johnson
could not
forgive paul kelso sky news